all right before we get started i want
to thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by raycon
raycon earbuds no stranger to the
channel the slick stylish true wireless
earbuds that remain to this day
my workout earbuds but they're useful
for a variety of reasons you want to
listen to a podcast or music
because you can they're discreet no
dangling wires or stems so
they don't make it weird and as always
they offer six hours of play time
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass and
a more compact design that gives you a
nice noise isolating fit they come in a
variety of colors so whatever your
flavor is you do you and among that they
have a 45 day free return policy
something with me i always appreciate a
good return policy so click the link in
the description or go to buyreicon.com
john's and get 15 off your raikon
purchase and as always thank you once
again to reikon for sponsoring this
video
i do appreciate it all right now another
week another episode of falcon and the
winter soldiers is falcon in the winter
soldier i believe it's episode five
yeah five and there's a spoiler warning
for episode five of falcon in the winter
soldier hold on gonna make sure it's
episode five hey look at that it's five
but regardless okay spoiler alert for
this episode of falcon winter soldier
moving on this episode was kind of like
the i don't want to say it was a chill
episode because it actually was
heavy just thematically speaking in
terms of some conversations also started
out with a fight a three-way fight
between johnny walker
bucky and sam you know after johnny
walker bludgeoned and
killed somebody then this fight was
pretty intense but that's the intensity
you get in terms of
physical activity regardless johnny
walker goes down and he is discharged
how did they say it wasn't dishonorable
discharge it was like
other than honorably discharged or
something like that and before the fight
actually went down
sam was of course talking johnny walker
down
because that's what sam does i mean that
was kind of his job
you know he was like no i i work with
vets and
i can do this but he's talking what's
her face down in the previous episode
he's talking johnny walker down and this
episode
always goes wrong something always
happens where a fight breaks up
you know sam tries i didn't kind of
scratch my head
is that why why does this lady sound
like agatha harkness what was her name
like allegra fontaine or something like
that i don't know what it is
like are they just like all right well
you know you're
this super sassy maybe villain maybe not
villain but
just talk like someone tried to write an
aaron sorkin character
talk like agatha harkness there you go
she sounds just like agave to the point
where i'm like
maybe she maybe she's mephisto bummer is
zemo's gone now
i guess bucky hands him over to wakanda
so that's zemo kind of a bummer he
didn't have more to do in the show
it's like he came in and he was
intriguing
and the memes just flooded the internet
and they were like all right that's
enough memes
that's we got our circulation for those
weeks bye zema and after all that really
it's just this episode kind of
winds down and weirdly that was my
favorite part of all of it bucky and sam
are working on the boat you know doing
some hard work getting some brewskis
going i was like i don't know
just seems like a pretty cool day
hanging out doing some hard work
chilling with friends and family
flirting with your friend's sister
respect to all of it after all the
excitement it's good to see people you
know let their hair down
kick their feet up i did like sam and
bucky bonding over
shield throwing it was like a couple
people throwing a baseball like i guess
adults don't do that when they talk
they just they throw back beers it's
like a father and son tossing a baseball
bonding time only as falcon in the
winter soldier but i did like a couple
of points brought up because sam was
like hey
what would steve think it doesn't matter
what steve thought or it doesn't matter
what steve would think however he
phrased it because i always think of
that i'm always like
what would steve think in fact what does
steve think
what does steve think about there being
a new captain america out there what
does steve think about the fact that
the friend he gave the shield to is not
him i feel like steve would poke his
head out of whatever retirement home
he's in
and he would give his two cents or maybe
not i don't know but sam was like
steve's gone that's what i was like
wait he's not playing bingo and eating
tapioca pudding what do you mean he's
gone is he dead did he die what do you
mean gone
so i have questions and more questions
but i also agree
the fact that it's like there's a how to
phrase it
i understand you want to do honor to
steve rogers but in the end
the choices are yours and that's really
this episode
hammers that home a lot also seen with
the conversation between
sam and isaiah bradley i like that
conversation because it shows a lot of
the layers of sam like
sam is struggling sam has the weight of
the world on his shoulders trying to do
right by his sister
their legacy their family legacy and now
isaiah bradley he wants to do right by
everyone this juggling act just seems
like an impossibility
but i feel like he will find a way and
in that conversation with isaiah you see
a couple of very important things there
one you see that quality of character of
sam he wants to understand where this
guy is coming from but also you can tell
that he doesn't see the world how isaiah
sees it which is a very important thing
that this
illustrates the fact that you can see
and understand where someone's coming
from without
living it through their eyes you know
without living their perspective that's
a very human
thing it's a very human thing to address
that you find in many
human interactions just not online don't
look for it there
you won't find it and then sam with the
training montage no more
softball frisbee throwing this was some
hardcore training where it's like no sam
is going
he's he's going for it sam's working to
be cat and buck he drops well i mean
bucky already dropped off this suitcase
he tells sam he drops off the suitcase
he's like i called in a favor with the
wakandans which i was like called in a
favor but
i don't think that's how calling in a
favor works how did that how did that
work was wakanda like hey bucky we fixed
your brain and bucky was like
great i'll call in a favor so you can
make it up to me
i just don't think that's how that works
pretty sure he owes them one
regardless they treat this case like the
briefcase from pulp fiction or something
you want to see what's in it but you
just don't get to in which i'm thinking
new falcon wings
or new captain america suit you imagine
that captain america suit but
vibranium cloth falcon america flying
around with his new wings and a cap
shield with a new suit
strike fear in the hearts of criminals
everywhere speaking of criminals and
that one girl in her crew they show up
again you know the ones that
i don't really care about but like they
were shoehorned into the show kind of
like how zemo was but at least zema
provided memes
anyhow it did crack me up this cracked
me off the fact that
i'm pretty sure sharon carter's the
power broker right
internet sniffed that out in like two
seconds they're like oh a power broker
yeah i'm pretty sure that's sharon
carter damn it
i thought we were more slick than that i
mean it hasn't really been confirmed
but it looks like it's her and they're
all hanging out in the park and this guy
drops off again another suitcase looks
like it has weapons or something in it
the main
girl you know the main super soldier
terrorist girl's friend just like we're
working with criminals now
she brings up a good point she's like
haven't you heard we are criminals
also i've bombed places and bombed
people and killed them so yeah
you've been working with a murderer all
this time but yeah go ahead posture the
moral high ground here
you posture enough moral superiority
we're gonna change your name to
disney so all right we'll be back to
action taking out the criminals i don't
really care about
that much because zemo's gone looks like
he's out of the picture so all we're
left with
are the boring folks but it gives sam a
reason to gear up and take him out
in which case i hope bucky's still a
part of it looks like bucky just kind of
was like all right peace
bye sam maybe we're gonna go on another
side quest because sam lectures bucky
he's like tough love
you gotta put in the work you know you
gotta you've been fighting you've been
an avenger
you know you've been avenging thinking
it'll help you out but it hasn't you
need to make the people you've wronged
feel good you gotta make them feel
better
in which case is he gonna talk to that
one dude who's sonny totally killed as
the winter soldier that makes me nervous
thinking about it man that gives me cold
sweats like how do you even start that
conversation you knock on the door like
i have something to tell you
we found the one who murdered your son
he uh we threw him into outer space
good talk bye that's gonna be a rough
conversation right there
that's gonna be the sebastian stan emmy
piece
that's gonna be the clip so in the end
among all the fights and the avenging
this episode was more down to earth it
actually really dug that
home before the storm most likely
absolutely
gonna be with the villains i don't care
about that's kind of a bummer but it'll
be neat to see what's
in that suitcase and what sam looks like
when he's
geared up to be captain america is
johnny walker just out
doubt it dude still has super serum
pumping through his veins pretty sure
he's gonna go rogue and
he believes he's captain america that's
what's gonna happen
super lame terrorist organization is
gonna rise up and then johnny walker's
going to be like i'm still captain
america and sam's going to have to fight
him and he's going to
fight him in front of everybody with
cell phones and people going to be like
sam is captain america all right that's
how it's probably going to end
i don't know for sure but i don't know
that's my head canon right now
until next week next week when we find
out the truth that it was all mephisto
all right so episode five of falcon in
the winter soldier have you seen it why
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here
to see more
you